[Musique]
et on analyse donc cette décision de la
Banque du Canada avec Jean-François
Perrot premier vice-président économiste
en chef à la Banque Scotia bonsoir
Monsieur Perrault
hausse de 50 points de base il y a des
économistes qui disaient qu'on aurait pu
avoir une hausse plus faible à 25 points
de base vous à la Banque Scotia vous
vous attendiez à ce qui a été annoncé
aujourd'hui donc pour quelle raison
est-ce que vous en êtes satisfait
effectivement c'est ce qu'on attendait
donc on est satisfait je dirais que je
suis plus satisfait du fait qu'ils ont
communiqué comme vous l'avez dit au
début du rapport qui vont prendre une
pause ou qu'on est peut-être même à la
fin de la hausse et tout intérêt
de ce qui est quand même une bonne
nouvelle dans la mesure où on approche
la fin aussi on n'est pas déjà arrivé à
la fin donc
est-ce que puisque cette hausse pourrait
toucher à sa fin est-ce que c'est
nécessaire d'avoir encore un demi point
pourcentage c'est à dire est-ce que
malgré les signes d'apaisement de
l'inflation
c'était nécessaire d'y aller avec un
autre hausse historiquement plus
important que celle auquel on peut
assister
de la banque on a eu évidemment des
données stations qui étaient un peu plus
faibles donc les ralentissement de
l'inflation était évident maintenant
c'est très bonne nouvelle par contre on
a eu des signes que le marché de
l'emploi demeure très fort on a eu un
rapport sur l'activité économique
canadienne du troisième trimestre qui a
été beaucoup plus forte anticipé donc
les signes de ralentissement que la
banque cherche pour
identifier vous confirmer une baisse
[Musique]
ces choses là font en sorte qu'il devait
augmenter 50 points de base moi c'est ce
qu'on pense pour répondre à cette
vigueur économique qui
est très bien d'une certaine façon on
veut évidemment que les choses soient
plus fortes mais cette guerre là le
malheureux est fait de soutenir
l'inflation un peu plus qu'on le
voudrait justement la croissance
économique et
3e trimestre sans même été plus
vigoureux que ce qui avait prévu la
Banque du Canada il y a rien qui exclut
que cette croissance sera encore
vigoureuse début 2023 donc les hausses
de taux d'intérêt on ne les exclut pas
complètement si je comprends bien on n'a
pas obligatoirement assister à la
dernière hausse la banque avant
plusieurs mois
ils savent très bien que l'augmentation
tôt qu'on a observé va prendre un
certain temps avant d'avoir son impact
maximal sur l'économie sur l'inflation
les taux augmentaient très rapidement il
y a une incertitude quant à l'ampleur de
cet impact là est-ce que ça va frapper
dur est-ce que ça va frapper lendemain
ce que ça va est-ce que ça va les effets
intentionnés donc cette pièce cette
question là mais d'abord et avant tout à
la question d'incertitude entourant
l'inflation l'inflation et le ralenti
c'est bien ça fait seulement quelques
mois que ça ralentit on n'a pas encore
assez de preuves ou de confiance dans la
dynamique dynamique impressionniste pour
être certain à 100% la plus bon 85 CAC
ça va se faire profil de l'inflation qui
diminue tout au long de l'année
prochaine qui retourne à 2% peut-être en
2024 donc c'est vraiment une question
d'incertitude sur la dynamique
internationaliste et force cette
constater que les gens comme moi les
gens comme la Banque du Canada comme les
autres à l'extérieur du pays ont eu
beaucoup de difficultés à prévoir à
prévoir l'inflation dans dernier mois
donc il y a l'incertitude là qui qu'il
faut être intégré là dans une
perspectives micronées
énormément de facteurs qui ont un impact
sur la croissance sur l'inflation
également mais on se pose la question et
c'est un scénario qui a été avancé par
certaines nouveaux collègues dans
d'autres institutions financières celui
d'une pause pour le les hausses du taux
directeur et peut-être même advenant un
scénario de récession une baisse des
taux d'intérêt plus tard vers la fin
2023 est-ce que c'est un scénario que
vous retenez
le scénario qu'on a on anticipe une
faible récession en début d'année mon
ralentiant économique important mais pas
nécessairement un gros choc on parle
d'une croissance de une perte d'activité
de points 2% sont quelques trimestres
c'est pas grave chose
mais ça devrait faire en sorte que cette
faiblesse là que la baisse de
l'inflation qu'on anticipe pourrait
permettre à la banque créa de réduire
cette taux d'intérêt dans un à peu près
donc commencez la baisse de taux
d'intérêt qui va mener à normalisation
éventuelle de ces taux là au fur et à
mesure que 2024 progresse je vous emmène
sur votre rapport monsieur Pérou bon on
a souvent dit que l'aide gouvernementale
avec la covid entre autres c'est
inflationniste vous vous êtes penché sur
le dossier vous avez même chiffré la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans le
niveau d'inflation actuelle quelles sont
vos conclusions
il y a deux conditions qui sont
importantes la première c'est
qu'effectivement l'inflation canadienne
a été influencée par des mesures
d'appendémie c'est normal on en a de
l'argent on a stimuler l'économie sans
un impact sur l'inflation c'est tout à
fait standard comme impact Macron
économique ceci étant dit l'impact sur
l'inflation est quand même relativement
faible étant donné l'ampleur des autres
chats qu'on a observait donc on parle
évidemment
de la reprise économique mondiale du
président des des charts des contraintes
de production tout ça un impact beaucoup
plus important par contre l'augmentation
de la demande donc l'effet sur
l'activité économique de ces mesures de
pandémie nécessite quand même une bonne
réaction de la banque Canada on anticipe
on estime à peu près 125 points de base
et lorsqu'on parle de l'augmentation
totale de 400 coins de base mais vous
voyez là c'est quand même un peu plus
que un peu plus que 1/3 de
l'augmentation totale donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est important
au niveau de l'activité économique mais
c'est parce que activité a été très
fortement affectée par ces mesures là
bon analyse très intéressante monsieur
perron merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI